This video is brought to you by Wix.
Street art has captured the world’s attention
in recent years, developing its very own graffiti
industrial complex.
Skater kid Shepard Fairey parlayed his 80s
sticker street art into a guerilla marketing
company.
He’s now worth millions.
90s graffiti artist Retna turned his scribbles
into a cool multi-million dollars worth of
fine art.
But the Coca-Cola of this market, undoubtedly,
is Banksy, the anonymous dude with that voice…
The guy built a fake, depressing Disney World,
made a debatably fake, amusing documentary
and shredded his painting right after it sold
for massive amounts of money.
He also bought a painting at a thrift shop
for $50, painted Hitler into it, and sold
it for charity for hundreds of thousands dollars.
People tend to think that Banksy is either
some asshole worthy only of parody,
“That’s when I told Lady Gaga, ‘No,
YOU text ME!”...
She texted me”
Or that he’s an artistic genius.
The real question is: What is Banksy trying
to do with his art, and is his work achieving
its intended goal?
We’re going to find out in this Wisecrack
edition on Banksy - Deep, or Dumb?
But, before we get to it - a message from
me, Mark AKA Garyx Wormuloid, about this video’s
sponsor Wix.
As an actor in LA it can be very hard to set
yourself apart, which is why I decided to
use Wix to make a professional website that I can shamelessly send out to Hollywood producers.
As you can see here, I went on there and I
just told them that I’ve never created a
website before, and it walked me through the
process step by step!
Within minutes I was uploading all my photos,
all my videos, and some Earthling Cinema highlights
- it was super easy.
So if you wanna step up your professional
game, head to wix.com/wisecrack or click the
link in the video description.
Garyx out.
Arguably the world’s most famous street
artist, Banksy is a professional prankster
best known for making satirical graffiti that
frequently depicts children, rats, and repurposed
iconography.
Typically, the images will be accompanied
by a slogan, and the various facets will combine
to form some sort of anti-war, anti-capitalist,
or anti-establishment message.
Of course, Banksy isn’t your typical street
artist - Even by art world standards, he’s
made a lot of money.
His estimated worth is over 20 million dollars.
What’s more, his art is no longer typical
street art - it’s frequently safeguarded
with plexiglass or removed from buildings
entirely to be protected for posterity.
Cool, but is it deep, or dumb?
Argument 1 - Yes.
Banksy is v. smart - the latest iteration
of a long-line of smart art people doing smart
art things.
Because art is often appraised and understood
by its relation to other art, we need to look
back to Dadaism.
Dadaism was a form of art that began in World
War I as a means of rejecting capitalism and
ridiculing the absurdity of modern life.
It manifested as form of protest art, and
one of its central practitioners was Marcel
Duchamp, who famously coined the term “anti
art” to describe work that challenges our
preconceived definitions of what art should
be.
Like, when he submitted a urinal on a pedestal,
titled “Fountain,” for an exhibition in
New York.
For this, he used the term “ready made,”
to mean an already-produced or “found object”
that is repurposed as art.
He chose mass-produced commercial objects,
typically ones that served a utilitarian purpose
- like, say, a urinal.
As he said:
“You have to approach the object as if you
had no aesthetic emotion.
The choice of ready-mades is always based
on visual indifference”
Duchamp was hoping that, by exhibiting something
that was explicitly NOT art, literally, anti-art,
he could ironically call into question where
our concept of art starts and ends, while
also arguing that anything, even a urinal,
could be art.
Of his readymades, he also said, “I don’t
attach any value—I mean commercial value,
or even artistic value—to it.”
So additionally, by displaying art that is
for practical purposes worthless, he is perhaps
questioning why we even value art in the first
place.
Cool.
For Duchamp, the “creative act” of art
was not the sole endeavour of the artist,
but a sort of collaboration with the spectator,
who contributes to the creative act by “deciphering
and interpreting it”.
With Duchamp, the reaction of his audience
was an essential part of the artwork itself.
While Duchamp never admitted exactly what
he hoped people’s reactions would be to his
pedestaled piss pot, he does seem to have
expressed regret at how people actually reacted.
Later in life, he bemoaned that “you can
make people swallow anything; that’s what
happened [with Fountain]” Duchamp seems
to be saying that, in attempting to challenge
the entire concept of “art”, he ended
up merely expanding the range of what kinds
of images and objects people would choose
to commodify and revere.
Basically, Duchamp wanted to make you scrunch
up your nose and picture your “art” covered
in piss, as a productive means of challenging
conventional notions of what art should or
shouldn’t be.
But instead of being grossed out, people were
like “Sweet, can I buy this used urinal
for 20 million dollars please?”
Which brings us to Banksy, who, like Duchamp,
critiques the pretentiousness of the art world.
Banksy argues that “Art is not like other
culture because its success is not made by
its audience.
The public fill concert halls and cinemas
everyday, we read novels by the millions,
and buy records by the billions.
'We the people' affect the making and quality
of most of our culture, but not our art.”
Like Duchamp, Banksy wants to “degrade”
the perceived snobbishness of the art world
by a) Using the everyday streets as his canvas
and b) Using familiar, simple images that
are universally accessible, regardless of
whether you just wrote your dissertation on
early Russian modernism.
Furthermore, Banksy’s work is all about
criticizing capitalism and consumerism.
Ironically, the popularity of his work triggers
rabid consumerism, being physically removed
from buildings to be sold in auctions on the
art market, or protected from the elements
with plexiglass.
Arguably, Banksy’s most Dada moment came
this past October when his painting “Girl
With Balloon“ self-destructed immediately
after being sold for just over a million pounds.
Banksy was following a specific tradition
of auto-destructive art invented by artist
Gustav Metzger in the early 1960’s.
Metzger famously used acid to paint a white
nylon sheet, in the process destroying it.
Auto-destructive art emphasized the audience’s
participation in the work, with artists typically
destroying their work in a public space.
The destruction, and bearing witness to that
destruction, was all part of the work.
But he was also referencing the tradition
of Dadaism, as that ironically “degrades”
or destroys the bubble of the art world.
In that way, Banksy’s latest work definitely
qualifies, by emphasizing the material fragility,
an ease with which “art” can be transformed
into a pile of strips.
Even if you’re not a Banksy enthusiast,
you can probably admit that it was pretty
punk rock.
More on balloon girl later.
But don’t worry Banksy skeptics.
There’s plenty here for you.
Argument 2: Banksy is irrelevant, his audience’s
opinion is all that matters.
According to the theory of structuralism articulated
by scholar Roland Barthes in his earlier years,
there is no foundation of meaning in an artist’s
intention.
Rather, meaning is grounded in whatever culture
and systems exist at any given time.
For example, the first caveman art critic
who looked at this ox was probably like “Daniel’s
really pushing his work to the next level,”
whereas we’re like “oh, cute finger-painting”.
Barthes, as he wrote in his essay “Death
of the Author” sees meaning as being anchored
in the culture surrounding art, and it’s
our job as cultural detectives to figure out
what the eff this means.
Structuralism makes sense when it comes to
an artist like Banksy, who purposely remains
anonymous and gives evasive answers about
his intentions.
By not declaring exactly what any one piece
of art means, Banksy is protecting our ability
to decide for ourselves, thus giving the audience
all the interpretive space in the world to
theorize and argue over answers we’ll never
have, such as whether or not his “documentary,”
Exit Through the Gift Shop is fake.
For an example of work that relies almost
entirely on societal context to be understood,
look at Banksy’s Kissing Coppers.
In the image two male police officers passionately
kiss.
This work was widely viewed as a repudiation
of homophobia, a middle finger to the ugly
tradition of the law telling people who and
how they should love.
However, compare Kissing Coppers to now-routine
images of President Trump and Vladimir Putin
engaged in various forms of romantic intimacy.
These images are clearly disparaging, suggesting
that Trump’s perceived subordination to
Putin is embarrassing or shameful through
the metaphor of gay intimacy.
In other words, if Banksy’s anonymity is
meant, smartly, to give more power to the
spectator and their interpretation, is that
completely ruined if half of the people read
your work in the opposite way you intended?
In the case of Kissing Coppers, did he set
out to mock homophobia, or was he merely trying
to humiliate cops by suggesting that these
stereotypical manly men harbor gay fantasies?
Does this ambiguity subvert Banksy’s ability
to accomplish anything?
Or does it unapologetically function as a
mirror to its viewer - who are free to interpret
it as either pro gay rights or simply homophobic?
Does his anonymity hinder his ability to communicate
his message?
Argument 3: There was never any chance for
Banksy to be deep because postmodernism.
For an even less flattering angle on Banksy,
let’s look to Thomas Mann’s postmodernist
theories, which hold that there’s basically
no way for a successful artist to critique
the art market through art.
Why?
Well, because the second they start making
art that is recognized by the commercial market,
they have thus entered said market.
So are all successful artists sellouts?
Would a Banksy, writhing around, broke, in
obscurity, tagging the streets of London be
more effective than rolling-in-dough Banksy?
Well, it’s possible.
That said, only rolling-in-dough Banksy could
pull off a project like Dismaland, a temporary
art project and “anti-amusement park”
that featured works from 58 other artists.
It sold out almost instantly, with six million
people trying to buy tickets and crashing
the site.
People waited for hours to gain entry.
It’s been criticized as something high-brow,
middle class millennials participated in to
feel better about themselves.
Arguably, in setting out to critique the self-indulgent
branded fun of amusement parks, Banksy simply
replicated that experience, with a snarky
facade.
If he set out to create an anti-amusement
park, he may have simply just made a hipster
Disneyworld.
Also, the project was criticized as not really
having anything to say besides “capitalism
bad.”
Let’s briefly jump back to Girl with a Balloon.
Here, Banksy pulled off a pretty cool stunt
that gave the middle finger to all the art
snobs bidding on his work.
However, after the piece was shredded, it
only increased its value.
As Leon Benrimon, the director of modern and
contemporary art at Heritage Auctions explains,
“It was meant to be a criticism of the art
market, and I think it’s going to double
the value of the work.”
This is the ultimate example of the “damned
if he does, damned if he doesn’t” conundrum
of being Banksy, or any other artist for that
matter.
You’d almost have to feel bad for the guy,
if he wasn’t a millionaire.
One last point on this - So Banksy’s anti
capitalist work has been incorporated into
the very capitalist system he dislikes.
Now people pay top dollar for his work:
“Selling for eight hundred and sixty thousand”
and retweet his art on the ad-soaked feeds
of Instagram.
But what if this is just proof of Banksy’s
success?
Here we are, at Dismaland or Banksy’s bethlehem
hotel or gathering around a random gas station
or a hoity-toity art auction to consume his
work.
What if us voraciously partaking in this system
- the very thing he’s making fun of - means
that the joke, quite simply, is on us?
On to Argument 4 - Banksy is deep because
he’s a culture jammer in the grand tradition
of Situationism.
The Situationist International (SI) was an
organization of social revolutionaries made
up of avant-garde artists, intellectuals,
and political theorists who ran around Europe
pulling artsy lolz from 1957-1972.
One of the group’s favorite tactics was
the Situationist Prank, a subversive political
prank, hoax or stunt.
For instance, when some Situationists dressed
up like monks, and gave a sermon on Easter
Sunday at Notre Dame announcing “Verily
I say unto you: God is dead.”
They used a technique called ‘détournement’,
French for ‘rerouting’ or ‘hijacking’,
which essentially means changing something
so that it means something entirely different
than its original intention, particularly
in regards to capitalist messaging.
Like if I write “Capitalism does not suck,”
on my store window, and you crossed out the
“not”, that would be a very dumb example
of detournement and nobody would be impressed.
Or say, painting blood on the Nike logo because,
you know, sweatshops.
Culture jamming, taking its influence from
the Situationists, tries to disrupt our environments,
which are so deeply saturated by corporate
and consumer imagery.
“The average North American consumes five
times more than a Mexican, ten times more
than a Chinese person, and thirty times more
than a person from India”
They do so by using mainstream language and
rhetoric subversively to critique the culture
and force us to reconsider it.
We definitely see Banksy interrogate these
questions in works like Slave Labor, which
depicts a young boy making Union Jack bunting
ahead of the Diamond Jubilee in 2013.
A pretty straightforward critique of sweatshop
labor, the image was painted on the exterior
of a Poundland discount store in London.
However, it was removed, framed and sold in
an auction for over 700 thousand pounds.
Ironically, what started as a provocative
stunt ended up being co-opted by the very
market forces Banksy was critiquing in the
first place.
Successful detournement?
Maybe not.
Compare his efforts to those of The Yes Men,
led by culture-jamming duo Jacques Servin
and Igor Vamos, operating under the mission
of using “humor and trickery to highlight
the corporate takeover of society”,
“I think Barry as well as all the other
protesters are simply, in a word, focused
too much on reality and on facts and figures”
The Yes Men made a name for themselves creating spoof websites and posing as corporate spokesmen.
In one example, they impersonated World Trade
Organization spokesman and pitched the idea
of using first-world waste to provide third-world
food.
“The number one, number two, number three,
number four, number five would no longer refer
to combinations of food, but rather just uh
- the number of times the product had been
recycled”
This functioned as effective culture jamming
because, for one, the performance couldn’t
be directly commodified (though it would be
memorialized in a Yes Men documentary film)
and it directly confronts the powerful - fully
employing corporate lexicon in service of
constructing colorful, elaborate lies that
reveal stunning truths about the full extent
of corporate greed, while indicting the cold,
calculated, fundamentally dishonest nature
of business-speak.
Instead, we might put Banksy alongside the
likes of fellow graffiti-artist Shepard Fairey,
whose Obey stickers might have once invoked
this anti-consumerist message in the film
“They Live” , but now adorns a $44 doormat.
Or, Supreme, who took the anarchists’ beloved
brick, an object perfect for sending through
a bank window, and stamped their logo on it
for a limited edition collectors item.
You can now buy one on ebay for over a thousand
dollars.
Radical!
So at the end of the day, what should you
think of Banksy?
Well whatever the hell you want, obviously.
You can find his art valid and construe meaning
but is it productive?
Not really.
Will it incite a revolution to overthrow capitalism?
Definitely unlikely.
Is its massive popularity and high value in
the art market necessarily at odds with its
success as anti-establishment intervention?
Almost certainly.
So what do you think?
Is Banksy deep, dumb, or somewhere in between?
And is art really better when nobody knows
about it?
Let us know in the comments, and if you wanna
build your own website with Wix, click the
link in the description, and as always - peace!